all right let's get into hatred mail for
the week we are going you know we've had
a lot of hatred mail related to
a lot of timely things about trump and
so on and so forth
today we're going back to an old
faithful in hatred mail but first quick
reminder about what hatred mail is
brace yourselves for the only
information
that can successfully penetrate a
tinfoil hat
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate
david pakman because america
and because freedom all right so here it
is just going back to
old-fashioned anti-semitic conspiracy
theories let's take a listen
hmm a jew is running the david pakman
show
what a coincidence you soft-spoken
stupid passive-aggressive idiot pac-man
who probably thinks that holocaust
happened to the jews
you have a million subscribers which
this jewish owned platform
owned by google's jewish owners and run
by a jewish woman that has promoted you
to get more exposure based on you being
a liberal
and a jew hasn't holocaust denial just
sort of become kind of boring like at
this point
is is that really where you're going to
put your eggs in the basket of
patriotism i just don't know
and of course if you're not familiar and
i envy you if you just don't know about
this a lot of conspiracy theories about
um you know the jewish conspiracy to
control media
and that's what is being implied by oh a
jew running the david pakman show what a
coincidence
wow don't fall for hatredism
fight against it with the coupon code
hatred 40.
the coupon code hatred 40 saves you 40
off of membership and it is a middle
finger
proverbially metaphorically uh to the
hatreds it is spelled h-a-t-r-i-o-t-40
it saves you 40 off of any membership at
joinedpakman.com
and the hatreds hate it because the
hatreds want to hurt the show
and when hatred 40 is used for
memberships patriots know
that they're the futility of their
hatred mail